the single greatest pursuit of every
young person today is the pursuit of
meaning now let's talk about your
journey here because it's been an
interesting one you you were born in
India and you were you were an atheist
until you were 17 is that right
again sometimes these stumps became
floated around in stronger ways than I
would like to have I was indifferent to
religious claims India's probably the
most religion manufacturing culture on
the face of the earth but most of the
major isms Hinduism Buddhism Sikhism
Jainism all of these isms were spawned
and raised in India and in India and
Pakistan are not separated there have
been the biggest Islamic nation - so
actually religion had no attraction for
me that's the best way to put it I felt
it was believing the incredible and it
was creating more havoc what was that a
strange position to hold as a young
person in a place that all those isms
came from I think so but you know we
never ever discussed it I don't drive
played cricket and I played tennis so I
was a sportsman in school that's where
you really talk after a game or whatever
I don't ever remember getting into these
discussions it flows with the culture
but the notion of God as a real entity
never entered my mind yeah maybe during
examinations
you know God if you're up there could
you help me and so on
I never took interest suddenly not in
the Christian faith even though my
ancestors came from the highest cost of
the hindu priesthood in the deep south
they were called in abou threes then
somewhere along the way there was a
conversion that took place into the
Christian faith and then that was lost
it became very nominal so I was really
raised I didn't have a single Christian
friend they were all either Hindu
Muslims about this so we never talked
about these things and then having had a
crisis experience in my life that
changed everything so let's talk about
that yes India is a culture of academic
excellence if you're not doing well
there you're in trouble and it's also a
culture of shame
when you're not succeeding academically
so I did the horrific thing I'm it till
this day embarrasses me because I don't
like talking about it took me a long
while to talk about it I attempted
suicide when I was 17 and it was not out
of any neurological disorder it was not
any biochemical thing it is a fact that
I just didn't have meaning there was no
purpose in life for me David I was
moving towards failure after failure
after failure and contrast to my
brothers and sisters and my father and
so tried to poison my system I thought
it was going to be successful I just
didn't like the way life felt and I
wanted to kill that feeling and to me
the only way to do that was you know
what they say in Belgium now there's
such a high rate of suicides they don't
call it suicide anyway they call it
opting out of life that would have been
a good description for me but it is on
that hospital bed a Bible was brought to
me my body was dehydrated I couldn't
hold it but the man who brought it to me
and gave it to my mother and scripture
passages were read to me and you know
when you're desperate when you're lying
like that words become very important to
you and when the words of Jesus were
read to me because I live you also shall
live that lit up within my heart
well what passage is that again John
chapter 14 and verse 19 Jesus strong
Thomas of all things because Thomas was
the Apostle who went to India and the
irony of it is in that same passage
Jesus says I'm the way the truth and
life no one comes to the Father except
through me it's pretty exclusive claim
dramatic claim and he went to a land of
330 million deities and he paid with his
life to present the Gospel message of
Jesus so that would like that verse
jesus said because I live you also shall
live I latched on to the word live I
said I don't know what this really means
but if God has a different definition of
this then I have I want to know what
that is and in a simple prayer I began
my pilgrimage to faith in Christ
what was that shift like I mean if we if
we were writing a movie right
now so there's the the young man who you
know attempt suicide the Bible comes to
him at in in the hospital bed he has the
wake up I mean it sounds like a movie
sort of what was the next shift in that
because it doesn't all just happen
immediately like well I appreciate you
asking these questions because you know
a they're pretty pointed and pretty real
to me the problem we often think Jesus
Christ came into this world to make bad
people good that's wrong it's not got
anything to do making bad people good
it's good coming to in the world to make
dead people live I was dead to the
claims of God upon my life I had no
purpose how do you find purpose without
a transcendent moral first cause you can
only lift yourself up by your own
existential bootstraps and assign your
own meaning the fact that I was created
for a purpose that I had an individual
distinctiveness that nobody else had
that God had a purpose for me in life
these were strange concept now of course
I'm looking in retrospect a when you go
back at that point my biggest hope was
like looking for a life lifeguard or a
lifejacket but over the process I found
out and I say this day that I travel
I've got about 70 countries
I speak hundreds of times a year the
single greatest pursuit of every young
person today is the pursuit of meaning
what does my life really mean even as
I'm talking to you I was talking to a
young man yesterday 18 years old who got
hooked onto pornography when he was 8
and he says and I've hated everything
that I have become and now all I want to
do is make an exit you see you take
something and warp it into something
else you empty it see you empty the
reality with something that's hollow so
that's what I've done with life so to me
the biggest change and my father said
this on his deathbed actually before he
went into the hospital for bypass and
when he lost life he said to me what
happened in your life is the most
incredible thing
I have watched happening from being a
failure during a different
and desires you have so what Jesus I
believe did for me was changed normally
what I did I change what I wanted to do
that I never left the top three in the
class after that I always used to be in
the bottom three
so my hungers change my desire has
changed and I think that is the biggest
transformation I noticed that's an
incredible statement for your father to
make right before passing did he have a
similar awakening or once you had an
awakening did it go across the family
yeah actually my brother my sister was
amongst the first to latch on to this
and then me you know when Jesus talked
to Nicodemus he made a fascinating
statement he said you can't change on
your own you have to express the new
birth now I know that takes on a
pejorative term in our ways but the fact
of the matter is new desires new hungers
are new breathing a new air and when he
watched my life change and what happened
yes he followed him which is very
unusual in the Indian culture there you
all follow your parents very rare for a
parent to follow the children but he
asked me to take him to the hospital he
was gonna have bypass I'm talking about
1979 so you know you're talking about 40
years ago it was relatively new my dad
was overweight he was asthmatic and
things had gone wrong physically but he
elected to have surgery but he had this
premonition I said I don't think I'm
gonna make it he was closer to my older
brother I was number two more like my
older brother and temperament but he
phoned me I lived in Niagara Falls
Ontario at that time 90 miles away sorry
five miles away he asked me to come and
take him to the hospital and on our
drive to the hospital that was a
conversation and he said what God has
done in your life and he also had had
that transformation through the work of
God in his heart you said the phrase
existential bootstraps which I like that
that that's kind of interesting do you
think some people can do it by
themselves do you think some people can
grab the existential bootstraps and not
have a religious belief or something
beyond themselves and still live a good
and moral life and all and a meaningful
life let's say I think so I think they
can but it does not have
ultimate grounding in a rationally
compelling way it has only that an
existence or transformation so yes of
course they can and I have many of my
friends who are like that they're good
people they are decent people and I
enjoy those friendships because we have
great conversations but the question has
to be David is what you believe
ultimately true or only
individualistically true for you and for
me and if that is the case then you
cannot absolute eyes it you can only
recommend it as pragmatically workable
for the now and then how do you disobey
somebody who by their own existential
bootstraps have come to the opposite
conclusions there's no antic referent
there's no point of reference to find a
solution to what is true and good and
beautiful if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality instead of non-stop
yelling check out our spirituality
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist there all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell